there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
[Music]
hey everyone happy comic-con week this
is gonna be my Black Widow trailer
breakdown because Marvel isn't allowing
us to post the footage online I'm trying
to do this the best that I can but there
was a whole bunch of footage of her
fighting taskmaster and Florence Pugh
just going full John wick inside the
Marvel Cinematic Universe there were a
whole bunch of Easter eggs they also did
some separate interviews revealing more
details that were not in the trailer so
we'll break it all down there's a new
round of that Avengers endgame blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
black widow moment on the video I just
broke this down top-10 style so cursory
spoiler warning for the Black Widow
movie but starting with number 10 the
footage begins with a montage of Black
Widow in all the other Marvel movies so
far with the following voiceover I used
to have nothing then I got this job this
family I was better because of it I've
made mistakes I can't go back those are
lines of dialogue that you probably
heard in all the Avengers and game
trailers it sort of informs her choice
to not let Hawkeye kill himself and her
take his place
David Harbor aka sheriff hopper also
said during all the interviews that the
Black Widow movie would help explain why
she did what she did on for Mirror
through the Marvel studio logo Flash's
number 9 there's this massive
establishing shot in boom the words
budapest flash on screen so of course
they're gonna be explaining all the
budapest references but she and hawkeye
keep talking about in these avengers
movies black widow walks in an old
apartment building in budapest with her
gun drawn she's being very cautious
there's a voice from inside the room
that says i know you're out there black
widow replies i know you know so do you
want to talk like grown-ups she turns
around the corner with her guns still
drawn still very cautious in their
standing is Jelena Bulova played by
Florence Pugh with her gun drawn on
Natasha is that where we are she says
eight they each tell each other to put
their guns down neither one of them does
there's still this tense beat it at the
exact same time using the exact same
moves each woman takes the gun out of
the other's hand now they have each
other's guns then they repeat the move
and steal each other's guns again then
they start fighting each other so seven
it's a very Winter Soldier esque John
wick fight
lots of punching lots of kicking
/ intensity you've seen most of Black
Widows moves the last couple of movies
so you can imagine that Jelena Bulova
Black Widow has the exact same moves so
they're pretty evenly matched
Black Widow grabs a towel and uses it to
smash yelling a Bulova into a sink she
wraps it around her mouth bourne-style
and starts choking her out
Jelena Bulova counters by grabbing a
plate smashing it into black widows head
from there is just complete madness it
really does feel like a born fight
they've gone full Captain America Winter
Soldier at this point birth Bucky
fighting Captain America at one point
yana Bulova grabs a huge kitchen knife
and comes for Black Widow the fight
continues on it ends with both of them
on the floor each choking each other out
with what looks like curtain rod then
they both wind up passing out so it dips
to black and when it comes back number 6
Black Widow is pouring two drinks for
them she says good to see you sis then
says you just had to come to Budapest
didn't you five they cut to a montage
Black Widow is running across this huge
mountain range it looks awesome there's
all these other Russian agents and
people from the Red Room pointing their
guns at her from rooftops there's a
motorcycle chase that looks like it's
right out of the Mission Impossible
movies then number four finally Black
Widow gets into a car that gets smashed
into a bridge in the night she's hurt
the car is burning but she looks out in
task master is coming for her so this is
one of the big boss fights from the
movie she shoots but taskmaster pulls
his shield out to stop the bullet so
remind you a little bit of an evil
version of Captain America or Winter
Soldier when he was still brainwashed
they start to go hand-to-hand fighting
each other they already have a very
similar fighting style but after a few
moves they both kneel and look up at
each other in the same position as if
they are mirrored obviously you know
taskmasters abilities involve copying
people's moves learning them on the fly
instantly even if you haven't read a lot
of taskmaster comic books you probably
remember him from Marvel's spider-man
ps4 they give you pretty good rundown
for what he's like what his abilities
are like you you were on my neighbor's
porch for Halloween names taskmaster
you're about to get taken to school you
know my moves you know I'm gonna wreck
you surprise me if you care who's out
taskmaster why are you stalking me an
organization hired rather be jonah
Jameson's foot masseur than work for
anyone who'd hire you your loss they pay
six figures so expect them to have a
little bit of fun with that with their
fights like Jelena Bulova has very
similar moves to Black Widow because
they were both trained in the red-room
program but taskmasters ability to copy
people's moves is a whole level beyond
that they give you a big close-up shot
of taskmaster with his special mask and
shield just to let you know that it is
taskmaster then the Black Widow shows in
the movie release date May 1st
2020 so as per usual with Marvel usually
their first trailers for their big
spring movies come out sometime in the
fall so they'll be releasing some of
this footage online pretty soon but
three the other big characters Rachel
Wiese is playing Molina Bostic off aka
Iron Maiden from the comics when the
film begins in the present day of the
movie remember this is set right after
Captain America Civil War she says her
character has been cycled through the
Red Room program five separate times
so most of her humanity has been
stripped away this is a clip of her
talking about her character I'm a black
widow and scarlet and Florence and then
they're there at least they're there
quite a lot of other characters that you
meet here also black widows so four
wasn't clear from that clip or the
general pitch of the movie the movie
will feature multiple black widows all
graduates of the Red Room program are
called black widows it's the Black Widow
program it's just the natascha black
widow is the most successful creation
the most prolific or most infamous
however you want to think about her
Rachel Lisa's character is meant to be
the darkest timeline example of what
could have happened to Natasha black
widow had she not gotten away from the
program and been taken in by Hawkeye in
Nick Fury and shield - Sheriff Hopper is
playing a less
see szostak HOF aka red Guardian the
Russian version of Captain America how
ironic that he's playing a character
named Alexi right after we all just
watched Alexi in stranger things
completely triggered David Harbor is
awesome I can't wait to see him in this
movie this is a clip of him talking
about his character look at his epic red
Guardian beard his Russians name is
Alexi szostak off and he is the red
Guardian who's the counterpart to
Captain America and he's also got a
tremendous history with Natasha Romanoff
Black Widow mainly they've known each
other for a long time and as she goes to
discover these things about herself he's
there he's a very surprising character
you sort of think in the beginning of
the film he's one thing and then he
becomes very much another there's a lot
of movement to his character a lot of
art there's all sorts of humor and
hearts which i think is a lot of these
Marvel movies and it's also it's in
another way this movie also feels very
grounded in a certain way that feels
like a real kind of almost indie movie
amidst this universe so it's really cool
so when he says the character changes a
lot over the course of the movie in the
comics he became the Russian version of
Captain America and was meant to be this
epic symbol for the Soviet Union the
same way that Captain America was a
symbol for the u.s. Allied forces during
World War two but he also got married to
Natasha
Black Widow but then later after she
defected and joined the Avengers he
tried to capture her and bring her back
to Russia to stand trial for crimes
against the state so translating the
ways that the movies usually changed the
comic books I'm assuming that he and
Black Widow just have a very close
relationship during the flashbacks when
she's still part of the Red Room program
prix budapest then in present day when
the movie picks up he resents her a
little bit for leaving him for leaving
the program but he's not the villain of
the movie he's not meant to be the bad
guy the real main villain was confirmed
to be taskmaster but they did not say
which actor is playing taskmaster so
this still opened a speculation but he
wears a mask most of the time so I think
the idea is that you don't find out who
he really is
till the end of the film number one as
you all probably wondered when Scarlett
Johansson was asked about Hawkeye being
in the movie recently on Good Morning
America
she got all flustered and said well we
have lots of surprises for longtime
marvel fan
which i think is just confirmation that
at the end of the movie in the
flashbacks will see Hawkeye showing up
in Budapest offering her a job with
shield seeing past all the terrible
things that she's done offering her a
better path for her life which was what
she was referencing in her final scene
during Avengers endgame right before she
dies they have a conversation talking
about him looking past all the things
that she's done I don't judge people on
their worst mistakes
maybe you didn't watching that clip
knowing how she ends up and why she does
what she does hopefully that gives you
an idea for how they structured the
Black Widow movie but like I said
easiest way to think about it is Marvel
doing a Bourne film or a John wick film
once they start releasing some of this
black widow footage online I'll do some
more Easter egg videos I'm also working
on a new blade teaser video that should
post in the next day but leave all your
Marvel video requests in the comments
below I know there are a lot of
questions after that big Marvel phase 4
reveal I'll name a giveaway winner when
I post that while you wait for
everything click here for the big Marvel
phase 4 panel and the Fantastic Four
x-men teaser and click here for my
Hawkeye trailer for the Hawkeye series
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]